hello everyone in all my previous videos
I've been discussing things meant
directly for the students in this video
for a change I wish to discuss a few
things meant for the parents of the
students especially those students who
are preparing to leave for college for
the first time
the same time my hope is that some of
the points that I am going to discuss
will be relevant to the students of the
second year third year and Beyond so if
you're a student and you see that some
of the points are particularly relevant
for you I request you to please share it
with your parents discuss it with your
parents also and if you are a parent my
request is that please do not view this
video as me giving some sort of advice
to you I do not have the audacity to do
that you are the parents uh you as
parents have uh much more experience of
Parenthood compared to me so I will not
encroach on that responsibility on that
on that enormous responsibility but I
would still like to highlight a few
points based on the experiences that I
have had as a child myself through my
interactions with my own parents through
the interactions that I have seen that
my my friends have had with their
parents and finally through my
interactions with the parents of the
students for whom I was The Faculty
advisor over the last few years here in
the mechanical engineering department of
IIT kharagpur the main issue that I have
regarding the interaction that the
parents have with their students is that
either on the one hand their interaction
is too much like they try to exert too
much control or be too much involved uh
with their children
on the one hand and on the other hand
some of the parents they are not at all
involved so both of these extra extremes
is extremely harmful for the students
now let us consider the first case
where the parents exert too much control
or are too much involved with the
students day-to-day activities whether
it is curricular or co-curricular
activities
we have to understand one very important
thing that
college life is not just an opportunity
for the students to learn things
academically whether it is in the
lecture hall from the professors or from
the books or in the labs it is also an
extremely good opportunity for the
students to grow up to grow up as mature
independent human beings so if as
parents uh
you exert too much control over their
day-to-day activities you do not let
them
take responsibility for their own
decision making process I think it is a
complete loss of that tremendous
opportunity
now I'm not saying that you should
completely let the students fend for
themselves in their decision making
process be involved but
do not exert too much control
now I also understand that suddenly if
you remove all your
advice or your involvement it can be
tremendously harmful especially for
those students who have grown up in a
very protective fashion or perhaps they
have grown up in a very sheltered
fashion so if you do that abruptly if
you take away that control or that
involvement very abruptly it can be a
kind of shock to the students so that
also is not very good so my feeling is
that this should be done in a gradual
fashion let them take more and more
responsibility of the various kinds of
decisions because ultimately that is the
definition of being an adult taking
responsibility for your own decisions
now let us consider the Other Extreme
case where the parents are forget about
exerting control they are not even
involved and words sometimes they are
completely unaware of what is happening
in the student's career they are not
aware when the exams are taking place
they are not aware of what the results
of the students are
okay so this is extremely extremely
undesirable and unfortunate what happens
is that in these kinds of situations
slowly slowly the students realize that
their parents are not at all involved
and they end up
starting to lie to their parents
regarding their results I have actually
seen this happen so the parents are not
aware maybe sometimes or after one or
two or three semesters they randomly ask
their students or the children what are
their results and then just to avoid
some kind of an uncomfortable
conversation the students just lie to
their faces okay and the parents also
don't follow it up so this is extremely
extremely dangerous it is dangerous
because this kind of a situation can can
and actually have led to uh to a
scenario where the students start to
have backlog semester after semester and
then one unfortunate day the parents get
a phone call from The Institute or from
the Department from some Professor that
such and such a thing has happened to
the uh to the students progress it is
that that there is absolutely no
progress and the student has so many
backlogs and then the parents are at a
complete shock because remember that
most of these students have been very
very good students in their school life
and suddenly the parents hear through
this phone call that ah they are failing
in their subjects their children are
failing in the subjects they have
backlogs okay and I am not trying to
make it sound more dramatic than it
actually is I have personally have had
this feel this this experience of
calling up certain parents and informing
them of their students lack of progress
and it is an extremely heartbreaking
situation both for the parents as well
as for me as a professor okay so please
do not let the situation come to such a
pass that this kind of phone call has to
be made my request to all the parents is
that sure you will accompany more in
most cases you will accompany your
children at the time of admission and it
is a yearly event when we see that the
parents are accompanying their children
to the to the various markets within the
campus and they help to buy the the
blankets the brooms the buckets and and
that is absolutely fine so
my request is that please do not stop
your involvement after you have bought
these things to them okay your
responsibility your involvement does not
end with these blankets buckets and
brooms okay so uh please keep a periodic
track of what is actually happening in
their progress in their academic
progress and not just academic progress
it is absolutely inevitable that they
will develop some other kinds of
Interest also maybe in music in some
sports also keep a track of what they
are doing uh overall above all my
request to all parents is to please talk
to your children on a regular basis
it may not be on a daily basis but at
least over 2-3 days or maybe at least
once or twice a week you please make a
phone call to your students to your
children so now it is all almost all
students have their mobile phones uh
please make this call okay I know that
because they are all young adults they
may not like talking to you on this
regular basis they may resist taking
your advice I mean we have all done this
I mean you as parents of teenagers you
already know what I'm talking about uh
and probably when you were teenagers
yourself you also did like that so it is
uh this is the story of life children do
not listen to their parents uh but uh
my request to you is that despite their
resistance please talk to them if you
are a little bit patient and talk to
them manage to talk to them just a
little bit uh I think you already know
that even if they do not say it
explicitly to your face they do not
thank you but later on they will
definitely thank you okay we all know
this from our own experience
and
finally my request is that when the
students
try to tell you something please listen
Okay like
especially in middle class families what
happens is that the
Parents try to uh
look at their children especially when
when they go off to these kinds of
engineering and medical colleges to
completely
Outsource their own unfulfilled dreams
and aspirations on the shoulders of
their children
uh that is unfortunate okay so even if
they have already joined an engineering
on a Medical College uh
it is possible that some other kinds of
interests May develop in their mind in
their hearts please try to listen to
them and sometimes when you call them up
they may remain silent they may
ah
resist talking to you at all or they may
just
randomly say some things but in that
silence in that lack of words also there
may be a cry for help so I request all
of you to please try to listen to those
unsaid words from your students so these
are rather heavy words uh I do not want
to end this video on a rather solemn
note rather I want to end it on a very
very positive hopeful cheerful note so
I I sincerely pray and hope that after
you have left your children
in the campus or maybe if you are a
parent of a second year student third
year student and Beyond uh
the ultimate interactions that you are
going to have with your students when
they return to you after their campus
life will be a tremendously joyful one
where many of the dreams hopes and
aspirations not just from your side but
from their side also gets genuinely
fulfilled this is my hope and pray
prayers for everyone for each and every
family so thank you very much and all
the best to you your children and your
entire family thank you